[Música]
los cambios en el clima y los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos han afectado
severamente américa latina' eventos como
huracanes tormentas eléctricas y
granizadas inundaciones repentinas y
sequías además olas de calor y de frío
son cada vez más frecuentes y comunes y
severas todo esto ha provocado el
desplazamiento de personas numerosas
muertes y también importantes pérdidas
económicas las tormentas tropicales
originadas tanto en el atlántico como en
el pacífico han devastado algunas áreas
de méxico centroamérica y el caribe más
allá de los daños causados en las zonas
costeras también son preocupantes los
efectos en las zonas del interior
saludamos entonces a natalia leber
directora de clima del reality project
en américa latina' natalia gracias por
estar con nosotros en esta mañana de
directo américa de france 24 digamos que
en el hemisferio norte en américa del
norte también en europa tenemos las olas
de calor pero qué pasa en américa
latina' como efecto de esta crisis
climática que podemos también nosotros
ver en nuestra región
hola raúl muy buenos días pues como dice
es américa latina es una de las regiones
más vulnerables al cambio climático
porque por nuestra posición geográfica
estamos afectados por huracanes
tormentas lluvias extremas sequías
importantes que están afectando ya la
disponibilidad de alimentos de agua el
80 por ciento de las personas en américa
latina vive en ciudades y pues sabemos
que el transporte no es el más eficiente
en américa latina también esto provoca
contaminación del aire afectaciones a la
salud y hemos tenido pérdidas
millonarias
por las pérdidas
en agricultura también por ejemplo
y lo más importante es que acá vemos una
oportunidad de transformar la manera en
la que obtenemos energía en la que
obtenemos nuestros alimentos
y tenemos que adaptarnos ya porque como
mencionabas esto está provocando que en
lugares como centroamérica en el
corredor seco ya la gente tenga que
emigrar porque no tiene que comer en la
crisis climática está poniendo en riesgo
el bienestar los empleos y la vida de
las personas en nuestra región ahora
este cambio esta crisis climática se
empieza a evidenciar también luego de
pasar por una crisis también sanitaria
como fue la del covite 19 también
pandemias y nuevas enfermedades que
podemos ver de los animales que se pasan
a los humanos precisamente por también
todo lo que estamos generando la
deforestación y ocupar territorios que
antes eran de los animales y por eso
entonces estas enfermedades pues se
pasan de animales a humanos como ve esta
situación actualmente y como la
podríamos ver en el futuro
bueno sabemos que hoy
alrededor del 70% de las enfermedades
infecciosas de los humanos provienen de
animales y eso tiene que ver con la
pérdida de biodiversidad
cuando empezamos a quitar los espacios
naturales a los animales entonces pues
las enfermedades pasan de los animales a
las personas también con la pérdida de
deforestación por ejemplo aumentan de
manera muy importante las enfermedades
infecciones y esto lo vemos
principalmente en la zona amazónica
también con el aumento de las
temperaturas estas infecciones que son
transmitidas por mosquitos aumentan
muchísimo ciudades como la ciudad de
mexico que no se nos se veían
infecciones por el ciclo de chikungunya
porque no tenemos tan altas temperaturas
bueno ahora ya esos animales se están no
solamente llegando sino reproduciendo en
las ciudades de no detener el aumento de
temperaturas ya podemos y vamos a seguir
viendo enfermedades pandémicas ya sea
transmitidas por vector
o por pérdida de biodiversidad
que pasan de animales a las personas
natalia pero digamos que eso es 1 día a
día no lo veo sano se ve que realmente
hay un cambio actualmente para poder
digamos mitigar y poder detener esta
crisis climática que todos los días se
acentúa aún un y aún más realmente que
se puede hacer o qué podemos hacer o lo
que están haciendo los gobiernos en este
momento para realmente detenerla y la
magnitud de lo que podemos vivir en un
futuro si no actuamos ya
monroe si lo vemos el problema es que no
hacemos la conexión entre el cambio
climático y las consecuencias que tiene
en nuestra vida ahora con las olas de
calor tan fuertes que hemos visto en la
región de américa latina
la pérdida de los glaciares en el área
andina en chile que ya no están teniendo
esa disponibilidad de agua las
consecuencias están ya lo que tenemos
que hacer mejor es comunicar lo que las
personas sepamos que las consecuencias
que tenemos en nuestra vida el día de
hoy en nuestra salud por ejemplo está
relacionada con la crisis climática
ahora las soluciones las tenemos hoy a
la mano y en américa latina como decía
este tenemos las de los mineros de
carbono y de agua más importantes de
todo el mundo entonces tenemos que
conservar nuestros bosques nuestros
manglares nuestros océanos para no
solamente hacer frente a la crisis
climática
aquí en la región sino ayudar al mundo a
poder hacer frente a la crisis climática
necesitamos transitar a fuentes
renovables de energía porque la quema de
combustibles fósiles es la principal
fuente de contaminación que está
generando el
necesitamos tener mejores prácticas
agrícolas que además que sean más
resilientes estos cambios de temperatura
también no se conviertan o no sigan
siendo una parte importante del problema
deforestando y emitiendo gases efecto
invernadero utilizando fertilizantes
entonces esas son las soluciones más
importantes que tenemos en la mano
algunos gobiernos de américa latina
vemos que no están haciendo pero tenemos
que mejorar las capacidades para poder
seguir
bien viniendo inversión a la región
natalia también hablaba hace un tema muy
importante que también hemos tratado
aquí en directo américa de france24 y es
el desplazamiento de las personas a
causa de este cambio climático que
lamentablemente pues vamos a seguir
viendo mientras todos estos fenómenos se
produzcan con más dureza digamos en
nuestra región esto por supuesto causa
una desorganización social también en
más pobreza más caos en nuestra región
como como se pueden preparar los
gobiernos de américa latina y el caribe
para que estas cosas no pasen con más
severidad en estas poblaciones que
además son las más vulnerables
bueno estamos medidas que necesitamos
dos cosas 1 alertas tempranas en américa
central y el caribe principalmente
para saber para podernos adaptar a la
hora que viene una lluvia extrema
un deslizamiento un huracán y estamos
alertas tempranas que ayuden a que las
poblaciones se puedan preparar
en primer lugar y en segundo lugar
necesitamos también mejorar los
ecosistemas como los manglares que nos
permiten ser menos vulnerables a estas
consecuencias del cambio climático y en
general adaptar también nuestros
sistemas de alimentación los sistemas
políticos porque sabemos raúl que estos
cambios están ya el cambio climático
podemos detener qué tan grave va son los
siguientes pero ya viene necesitamos
estar mejor tenemos tener alertas
tempranas de estar mejor adaptados tener
ecosistemas armadas más sanos y
agricultura pues con mejor tecnología